The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR STRANG:
OK, let's start
with a review and preview.
I put a P up there
because we're really
looking into the Fourier part
that just started this morning.
And there'll be some homework
from these early sections
about the Fourier
stuff, so we maybe we
should just do a few of those
problems or discuss here today.
Just in advance.
Can I say one thing about MATLAB
and the MATLAB homework first?
And maybe open a
conversation about it?
So there's really two
different problems
that I'm personally
quite interested in.
Two model, I'll
say model problems
because they're for regular
polygons in a circle.
And I'll draw an octagon again.
So M sides.
And I'm interested in
as M goes to infinity.
two different problems.
So one of them is our MATLAB
problem, is Laplace's equation.
What was it, four?
With u=0 on the circle.
OK, so that's our problem,
totally open for discussion.
How many have started on that?
Oh, good.
OK.
Well, then you all know
more about it than I.
And that's great.
I'd be happy to learn.
So have I said everything there?
Yeah, we've got Poisson's
equation inside.
We've got u=0 on the circle,
so the problem's well defined
and the solution should be
one minus x squared minus y
squared.
So that's the correct solution.
Maybe I can also tell you
about the second problem
that I'm interested in.
Because it hasn't come
up in class but it's
very important too.
It would be the
eigenvalue problem.
So this is problem number
one, the steady state problem
when you've got a source
and you want to find out
the temperature distribution.
The problem number two would
be the eigenvalue problem,
-u_xx-u_yy.
I take those minuses so that
the eigenvalue will be positive.
So that's what the eigenvalue
problem might look like.
And again let me say,
with u=0 on the boundary.
On the circle.
OK, so a person would say this
is Laplace's eigenvalue problem
because we have
Laplace's equation.
We've got eigenvalue.
As always, it's not linear
because we have two unknowns,
lambda's multiplying u.
And we have boundary
conditions, and this
would describe the normal
modes, for example,
of a circular drum.
If I had a drum--
Or a polygon drum.
So maybe I connect, to
actually build the drum,
I might fold in the sides
there and have a polygon.
And again, I hope
that the eigenvalues
of the polygon, this
equation in the polygon,
which are not known, by the way.
To the best to my knowledge,
we know it only for M=3,
which would be an equilateral
triangle, and M=4,
which would be a square.
And those eigenvalues, because
of Fourier or something
are humanly doable.
But I think five on up is,
I may be wrong about six,
I'm not sure about M=6, a
hexagon sometimes gives you
enough help.
But beyond that
you're on your own.
With finite elements
to help you.
So there's a whole sequence
of eigenfunctions u,
eigenvalues lambda, just the
way there were in one dimension.
And on the circle
they involve Bessel.
That's where Bessel showed up.
He figured out the
functions and they're not
especially nice functions.
But they're studied
for centuries.
Bessel functions come into that.
But, here I have
the same question.
I mean, let me just say, for
me this could be a UROP project
if anybody was an
undergraduate, or it
could be a project over
January or something.
I'd like to know
something about what
happens as M goes to infinity,
as the polygon approaches
the circle.
So I'm hoping maybe on
the homework that come in,
if it's not too difficult,
and maybe it's not,
to let M go up a bit.
There is one thing.
That the code we're working
with is linear elements, right?
We're using linear
finite elements.
So we're not getting
high accuracy.
So I would really
like to move up
to quadratic elements,
at least, you
remember quadratic
elements would
be ones where-- Well, let
me draw the one that we've
drawn in class before.
We only have to
look at one triangle
and then we cut it up
into triangular elements
by taking some pieces here,
taking the points above,
which I hope are now
correct on the website.
Connecting those edges,
and then connecting these.
Is that right?
Is that our mesh?
So that mesh is controlled
by N. One, two, N points.
Also, N is going to have to get
large too, to give me accuracy.
And another way
toward more accuracy
is, instead of linear
elements, second degree.
So do you remember
I wrote those down?
Let me take that little triangle
out here as a bigger triangle.
It would look something
like that, I guess.
The second degree elements
have those six mesh points.
You remember I drew those but
we didn't really have time
to get further with them.
The trial functions phi, which
are one at a typical mesh
point and zero at all the
others, they are computable.
We're up to second degree, so
it's a little-- Second degree
things, then the
first derivatives,
which come into the
integrations, are linear.
And not constant.
So a little bit harder.
But finite elements, linear
or quadratic, or higher,
could be used for this problem.
As we know, and
for this problem.
What I wanted to add, that
I've not mentioned in class,
and I think we may just
not get a chance to do it,
is what does the finite
element method look
like for an eigenvalue problem?
Because eigenvalues
are highly important.
That's the different
way to understand.
There's the matrix
K and its entries.
But then there are
the eigenvalues.
And you might
think that, what do
you think is the discrete
eigenvalue problem copying
this one?
Here's my point.
Your first guess would be,
well this is like K, right?
This is like KU, right? (K2D)U,
I should call it, maybe.
Well, I'll call it K, because
K2D I have specifically
reserved for the
Laplace stiffness
matrix on a square mesh, square
mesh with triangles, the K2D.
That was one specific matrix
for one specific mesh,
and here we have
a different mesh.
So I should just call it K. Ok,
I think if anybody was going
to make a guess, they
would say OK, KU=Lambda*U.
Maybe I'll use capital Lambda,
because I'm using capital U.
Is this the finite element
method eigenvalue problem?
And if you answered yes,
I would have to say, well
that's a reasonable answer.
But it's wrong.
The eigenvalue problem, when I
take the differential equation
for the Laplace,
Laplace's equation,
lambda u on the right side,
and I go to do finite elements,
it produces K.
Out of this stuff,
out of the weak
form, all that stuff.
But it produces another
matrix on the right-hand side
from the constant term, and we
have not really mentioned it,
it's the mass matrix.
So this, instead of
just the identity here,
there's a mass matrix.
So that is the problem
that you could do.
I could've made
a MATLAB project.
I bet I'd do it next fall.
Right?
You guys did the
first one, this one.
Or you are doing it now.
And I'm going to pause in a
minute for questions about it,
or discussion of it.
But this one brings in something
called the mass matrix.
So let me just say
what those are.
If I write down the
entries in the mass matrix,
you'll sort of get an
idea of why they are.
So what are the entries
in the stiffness matrix?
K_ij, you remember, is the
integral of the d phi_i/dx,
d phi_j/dx.
Plus d phi_i/dy,
d phi_j/dy, dxdy,
and that's what's
you're computing.
And that's what that
code is computing.
And when phi is
linear, phi linear,
then slopes are constant.
So all you have to do, and what
that code in the book is doing,
is figuring out
what are the slopes.
These things are
constant, so we just
need to know the area
of the integration
where we're integrating.
The area, triangle by triangle.
Fine.
That's what we're doing.
That's what that code
is just set up to do.
Now, I have to tell you what
is M_ij, the mass matrix.
I just think you
don't want to have--
we haven't done too badly
with finite elements in here.
We did it in 1-D, where we
got it kind of straight.
And now we're seeing what
it looks like in 2-D.
But I had not really
mentioned a mass matrix.
So here it comes.
The mass matrix
will be the integral
of phi_i times phi_j dxdy.
It's the zero order, no
derivatives, just plain zero
order, as you'd
expect from the fact
that the term in the
continuous part is zero order.
So it's this mass
matrix that comes in.
And maybe we could just look to
see which entries will be zero
and which will not.
How sparse is it?
What does the mass
matrix look like?
And can we just,
let me do 1-D first.
So there's a phi, right?
There's another one.
So, what do you think about the
mass matrix, one phi multiplied
by another phi and integrated?
Is it diagonal?
No, because each phi
overlaps its two neighbors.
So tell me what kind of a
matrix M is going to be?
In 1-D. Tridiagonal.
It'll be tridiagonal.
Now, so was K. So
K and M actually
have non-zeroes in
the same places.
the same sparsity pattern.
But, of course, not the
same numbers in there.
K had minus ones and twos
and fours and minus ones.
What can you tell me about
this tridiagonal matrix?
When I integrate that
against this, well,
again I would do it
element by element
because this against this,
they only overlap here.
Right?
I'll just draw the one
place that they overlap.
And what's the point?
They're both positive.
So the mass matrix is, its
rows don't add to zero.
Its rows tend to add to one.
But it's not diagonal,
that's the difference.
OK, so I just felt
I couldn't feel--
I wouldn't have done a
decent job in describing
finite elements if I
didn't describe this.
Didn't mention this mass matrix.
And maybe I'd better
say where it comes from.
Because eigenvalue problems, it
may come number two, but that's
pretty high up the list.
So let me tell you where does
this mass matrix come from.
First, let me tell
you about eigenvalues
of a-- matrix eigenvalues.
So the answer was, is this
the finite element eigenvalue
problem?
Only if there's an M there.
And now I want to, OK, first of
all, what MATLAB command solves
that problem?
Let's just be a little
practical for a moment.
What MATLAB command
gives me the matrix
of eigenvectors, the
matrix of eigenvalues
would come from eig of what?
I'd call this the generalized
eigenvalue problem.
Generalized because it's
got somebody over here.
And it's just K,M. Or of
course you get the same answer,
well you get the
same eigenvalues,
I guess the same
eigenvectors, yeah, if you--
Or eig of M inverse
K, of course.
If you want to do it
with just one matrix
then bring M inverse over here.
But, M inverse, the inverse
of this tridiagonal matrix,
is full.
No zeroes in the inverse.
So everybody would much prefer
this tridiagonal-tridiagonal
one.
So that's how
MATLAB would do it.
And what I want to know
is, back in this problem,
how close do the
finite element guys
come, on polygons, come to the
correct solution on circles.
I'm hoping that for
problem one you can maybe
keep M and N equal,
or maybe N may
be four times M or something.
And let them grow and see.
Well, for example, at
the center of the circle,
or how quickly do you approach
the correct answer, one,
at the center of the circle?
I think it's going
to be a good problem.
Let me open to, so I started
out just talking there.
What about the MATLAB problem.
You made a start
on it, is it going?
Have you got a graph, maybe,
or what's reasonable to graph,
to give Peter to look at?
Who's done something
on that MATLAB problem?
Yeah, go ahead tell
us all what to do.
AUDIENCE: I made the
triangle bisection and--
PROFESSOR STRANG: OK, right.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] and I
found that the [INAUDIBLE]
changes to M.
PROFESSOR STRANG:
With M more, I see.
So if you just fixed M
like eight, and let N get,
it didn't change significantly.
It wouldn't, of course,
converge to the right answer.
It'll converge, if it does,
to some kind of an answer,
for the polygon.
Right.
That's right.
So you know, as I
wrote the problem
I didn't know
whether I dared say
let M get increased
too, but of course
that's the real question.
And what happened then?
Did error shrink?
OK, and now maybe it's
possible to see how fast
or something that's always--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: Ah.
OK, at the center.
OK, then I hope
for more comment.
Let me say one more thing.
My theory is that the
error at the center
is quite a bit smaller than the
error closer to the boundary.
I would be interested in an
error-- Is it fairly even?
Oh, my theory's wrong.
It wouldn't be the first time.
And maybe because it's linear.
Yeah, my theory is more for
better elements, like these.
I'd be interested to know.
Why do I think, why
do I have this theory,
which you guys are going to
prove wrong anyway, but still.
After you've proved
it wrong, you
won't listen to me
if I tell it to you.
So now I'll tell it.
My theory is that the
error around the boundary
is, there's no error
at these vertices,
and then there's
sort of a going to be
an error because the real
answer is not zero along here.
It's sort of near
zero, but not quite.
You know, there's an error.
So there's errors around
here, from getting
the boundary wrong.
Squaring it off.
But my theory is that
errors, the boundary stuff,
drops off quickly
as you go inside.
That's why I think, from those,
you remember those-- Well,
we'll see them again
either today or Friday,
those r^n*cos(nx) type things?
That cos(n*theta)?
Yeah, you remember those
are the typical solutions
to Laplace's equation.
And then so that if-- And it
has some coefficient, of course,
a_n.
And I look at that, that
might be a piece of error.
And it's way bigger when
r is one and way smaller
when r is zero.
So anyway, that's
sort of my theory.
That if you have--
Like, physically.
You have a circular
plate and you're
maintaining the
boundary temperature
at some sort of oscillation.
Like, near one but
up and down from one.
Then I think further
inside, it doesn't know.
It hardly knows about
that oscillation.
This is my theory.
That toward the center
of the circle it
only sees kind of an
average boundary temperature
and not your little
ups and downs.
So when M is big, I
expect that part of error,
the up and down part, to be not
so significant in the center.
Anyway, now that's my theory.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG:
Ah, good question.
So if we only looked
at the center,
would it all be the same?
I mean, if we're only
looking at that one point
where it should be one at the
center, but along the thing,
I don't know.
If you look at both, and
see a significant difference
in the behavior
I'd be interested.
Yeah, yeah.
You know, all these problems
are things that there's
no single solution to.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: The error
between one minus r squared--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: Oh, right,
we've got slope error, too.
That's a very significant point.
I see, right.
So the slope error's in there.
Everybody knows,
then, everybody--
In working the
problem, I mentioned
that the boundary conditions
in this piece of pie
were zero along here
and normal derivative,
somehow it got printed du/dh,
but that was an accident.
It should've been
du/dn, dn is zero.
So Neumann conditions
on the thing
and then I was a little
scared about that point,
but I think phooey on it.
It's just, don't worry about it.
But what I was going to say.
How do you, what do you do to
take into account this du/dn=0,
this slope condition on
these long boundaries?
What should you do
in finite elements
to take account for that?
And the answer is,
in one nice word?
Nothing.
Right, nothing.
Your finite element
method should not,
you don't impose any condition
along these boundaries.
Just use the code as it is
with zeroes on this boundary.
And it should work, yeah.
It should work.
Any comments on--
Other people, did you
get reasonable results, or?
Tell me something.
Because you guys looked at
those graphs and I have not.
Any feedback yet?
On those?
I'm happy to get
email, too, about.
So all the email,
first of all they've
corrected the typos in the
original coordinate positions.
And now they've
pointed out I'd better
look at M is very, very welcome.
It doesn't mean that
everybody has to do this,
if you've completed
that MATLAB assignment,
you never want to see it again,
and you've kept M=8, it's OK.
But if you're
interested to see what
happens if M goes to 16 or
32, I'm interested also.
Right, yeah.
OK, so anyway that's the problem
we're really thinking about.
And that's the problem
that is equally important,
but it seemed reasonable
just to do one of the two.
And we were set
up to do, we have
the code for the
stiffness matrix,
we would need a new code
to do these integrals.
Because this will be
linear times linear, right?
I'll have to compute
that one times this one
and I would need new
formulas that are not there.
I'd need formulas for, this
will be linear times linear
so I'll be integrating
x squared type stuff.
And xy's, because I'm
2-D, and y squareds.
So it would take a little
more code, but not much.
I think the math-- Oh,
here's a question for you.
Here's a question for you.
Suppose I have my trial
functions, phi_i(x).
What do they add up to?
Let me again draw a
mesh, so I've got a mesh.
These are, you
know-- I'm sorry, I
want to put in some
more triangles here.
Lots of triangles, whatever.
Let me get some
more vertices, too.
I'm getting in trouble.
OK, whatever.
So phi_i is the piecewise linear
guy that is one at node i.
So I've got all these
different nodes.
I need a node there, so I've
got one, two, three, there's
a node, there's more nodes.
If I add them all
up, this is just
like in an insight question.
I've got all these, you
could add up these hats
in 1-D. What's the sum of
the hats in one dimension?
One.
Good.
The sum is one.
It's a nice fact that
these guys add up to one.
And now why is it
still true here in 2-D,
that these little
pyramids will add to one?
That's an insight question,
but it's worth thinking about.
Why do those
pyramids add to one?
Let me leave that question.
I'm thinking about, we haven't
imposed any boundary conditions
yet.
We've got them all. and I
claim that if we add up all
the pyramids including the
boundary chopped off pyramids
from the boundary, that we'll
get one throughout the whole,
now it'll be phi(x,y).
Because now I'm moving
to 2-D, with pyramids.
I think we'll still have one.
Let me give you a minute
to think about that one.
And then we could turn
to Fourier questions
if you would like, we could do
some problems from the text.
Any thoughts about this guy?
Why should all those individual
pyramids add up to a flat roof?
Why did it work here?
Well, it worked because you
could see it, right, somehow?
Does it still work if the
nodes are not equally spaced?
So we've got a hat
function for that guy,
and a hat function for
this guy, and a hat
function for this guy.
And these guys
are in there, too.
We haven't imposed anything.
So those one, two, three,
four, five functions,
five phis, they add
up to one, and why?
Well, you're going
to say it's obvious,
but that's what professors
are allowed to say.
Things are obvious, you
have to actually say why.
Which is not as easy.
So, why do they add to one?
Let me look inside one element.
Why does the sum
of these two guys
add to a flat top
inside that interval?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: At the
end points, you've got it.
Because what's happening
at the end points?
This guy, one of the guys,
the right guy is one.
And all other guys
are zero, right.
And this guy is also at one.
Because it's the right guy.
It has height one
and all others zero.
So at the nodes we
are at one, because
of one person,
really, one element.
And then?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: Right.
But the sum of them is, why
is the sum of them always one,
why is slope zero?
Yeah.
The slopes cancel, right.
We know that in between it
will be a linear function.
That would be one
way to look at it.
If I add up a linear function
and a linear function
the sum is a linear function.
So I'm getting a
linear function,
which is one at those points,
so what is that function?
One.
Right, you know that's
the straight line.
So, that idea will
work here too.
Look inside some
little triangle here.
OK, that's got one,
two, three corners, OK.
And if I look at this sum,
what is it at this point?
If I look at that
sum at this corner,
one guy is one, the
one for that pyramid.
And all others are?
Zero.
So the sum is one there,
the sum is one there,
so that blowing up
this little triangle,
this is at height one,
so what's the roof?
Flat.
It's just a nice way to see the
nice property of these phis.
That there's a phi for every
node, and they add to one.
To that's it.
OK, well I was going
to say one more thing
and I am, about this
eigenvalue problem, just
because I'll never
have a chance again.
So this is the moment
to say something
about the eigenvalues.
Lambda.
Eigenvalue.
I'm answering the question
where does K come from,
where does M come from?
Well, the eigenvalue is-- Voy we
really got dramatic music here.
Is that the Great Gate of
Kiev, I think might be.
Mussorgsky.
If you like drums and big
noise, it's not music actually,
but you got a lot
of noise out of it.
Well, of course, he'd know
more than we do, but still.
OK, so the eigenvalues in the
matrix case, for Kx=lambda*M*x,
the eigenvalue problem,
lambda, the lowest eigenvalue,
lambda_lowest, has
a nice property.
It's the minimum of sort of our
energy over our other energy.
I just think, well this is
something you should see.
This is a quotient here.
It's got a name called
the Rayleigh quotient.
And it would appear in the book.
So really, I guess
what I'm doing
is calling your attention to
something that's in the book.
That this a ratio of x
transpose K x to x transpose M
x, if I look over all
vectors x, the lowest one
is the eigenvector.
The best x is the
eigenvector and the ratio
is the eigenvalue.
This is like my point that I
wanted to mention the Rayleigh
quotient.
Here it is in the
matrix case, and there
would be similar
Rayleigh quotient
in the continuous case.
I'll just leave it at that.
That in describing
eigenvalues, we can talk about
Kx=lambda*M*x, like this.
Or we can get energy into it.
And you remember the whole
point about finite elements
is, look at the energy.
Look at that the quadratics.
Multiply things by things.
It came from the
weak form, it didn't
come from the strong form.
In the differential
equation here, we just
have single terms.
We got to these things
through that process
of multiplying by
u's and integrating.
That's what gave
us these products
and it works also
in the matrix case.
OK, that was a lot
of speech-making
about topics that we simply
didn't have time for in class.
I'm ready for any
question, or I'm
ready to maybe do a Fourier
example, would you like that?
Because this is
where we really are.
I'll even take one that
will be on the homework.
Just so you'll have a start.
OK, let me take a square
pulse, yeah this is a good one,
I think.
In Section 4.1, there's a
question for the Fourier series
of a square pulse.
OK, so what does the
square pulse look like?
Here's minus pi to pi.
Here's zero.
The square pulse
goes along here, up,
square pulse, and down.
Actually, let me go to L/2,
oh I'll just call it h.
Let me find the Fourier
series for this function.
It goes along at
0, it jumps up to 1
over a interval of length
2h, going from minus h to h,
and then back down to
0 and then repeats.
So bip bip bip, square pulse.
So that's my function.
Is that function odd,
or even, or neither one?
It's even, so I
can call that C(x).
And figure that I'm going to
use cosines for that one, right?
So tell me a formula for
the coefficients, what's
the integral that I have to do?
So my C(x) is going
to be some a_0,
we have to think what's a_0,
then a_1*cos(x), a_2*cos,
and so on.
So on.
a_k*cos(kx).
OK, what's the formula for a_k?
Before I plug in that function
I would like to get the formula.
So I'm looking for the formula.
It's a formula to remember.
So I'm not wasting your time.
Because you're going to see
it on the board and it'll
just take a mental
photograph of it.
What do you think
it's going to be?
How am I going to get it?
I'll multiply both sides of
the equation by cos(kx), right?
And I'll integrate.
So and then when I integrate,
the cosines are orthogonal.
Just like the
sines this morning.
All those terms will go,
except for this term.
When I multiply this by cos(kx),
I'll have cos(kx) squared.
Here I'll have a
cos(kx), and here I'll
have a whole lot of cos(kx)'s
but when I integrate,
all this stuff is
going to disappear.
And this will all disappear.
This is it.
So a_k is going to be the
integral of my function,
times cos(kx) dx.
Divided by what?
Divided by the integral
of cos(kx) squared.
Because I haven't
normalized things.
So I don't know that that's
one, and in fact it isn't one.
So I have to remember
to put that number in.
OK, so that's the
formula and that number
turns out to be pi, again.
If I'm integrating
from minus pi to pi,
then the average value of
the cosine squared is a 1/2,
it's sort of as much above
1/2 as it is below 1/2,
and so the average is 1/2,
the interval is 2pi, so pi.
OK, that's the formula.
Please just take a
mental photograph.
Catch that one.
Alright, now I've got
my particular C(x),
my square wave, square pulse.
Very, very important.
Very important
Fourier series here.
Famous one.
OK, so what do I have?
From minus pi to pi,
so what's my integral?
Well, my integral really
doesn't go from minus pi to pi
because my function
is mostly zero.
Where does my integral go?
Negative h to h, right?
And in that region,
what is C(x)?
One.
So you see it's
going to be nice.
From negative h to
h, where this is one,
I just have to integrate
cos(kx), so what do I get?
sin(kx), over k, and a pi.
So you see again that that k is
showing up in the denominator,
and that's going to give me
the typical decay rate of 1/k
for functions with steps.
For step functions.
And now I have to evaluate
this between minus pi and pi.
And-- No, h.
Better be h.
I mean, minus h and h.
So what do I get for that?
I get sin(kh), right?
At the top, and what
do I get at minus?
So I now I want to subtract,
what is the sine of minus kh?
It's negative, right?
So as I expect with an
even function like cosine,
am I just getting twice?
I could take it from 0 to
h, and it would give me
one of them and the other one.
Yep, I think so,
and divide by k*pi.
So those are the
Fourier coefficients.
Except for a_0.
a_0 has a slightly
different formula,
because for a_0, why
is a_0 different?
How do you come up with
a_0, and what's its meaning?
a_0 has a nice meaning,
so this is worth
having come this afternoon for.
a_0 will be what?
Well, I could get
it the same way.
What will I multiply
both sides by?
If I want to pick off a_0?
Just one.
It's not a cosine, it's
the cos(0x), it's the one.
And then I integrate.
I'm just going to
get the integral
from minus pi to
pi of C(x) times
one, divided by the
integral from minus pi
to pi of one times one. dx.
Same method.
Multiply both sides by one,
which was the very first
of my orthogonal functions.
Integrate it, all the other
integrals went away, right?
The integral of cosine
over a whole interval.
It's periodic.
You get the same
at the two ends,
so the difference is zero.
So we just, the only term
left was the constant.
And now what is the integral,
what's the denominator now?
That was the little,
slight twist.
2pi.
The denominator's 2pi.
Yeah.
That's that's why it's not,
yeah, it's slightly irregular,
I have to divide by 2pi.
And now, what word would
you use to describe,
if I have a function,
and integrate it,
and I divide by the
length, what am I getting?
There's an English word that
would describe what this is.
Average.
This is the average.
And it has to be.
This constant term is
always the average.
And what will it be for this?
So this was a_k, and
what is a_0, then?
So you can now tell
me, so everybody's
remembering this formula,
you integrate the function
and divide by the 2pi.
Now we've got a
particular function,
so what is the integral
of that function?
So what does this equal?
For this particular C(x)?
What's the area under
that function C(x)?
2h.
Right?
So 2h/(2pi), cancel the twos.
So there's a constant
term, a_0 is h/pi
and the cosine terms
are-- yeah, actually
we're going to get
something nice.
A really nice way
to complete this
will be if I put this together,
put this series together.
So now I'm saying that this
square pulse is that constant
term h/pi plus
the next term a_1,
you can see all these
terms have 2/pi's.
I'm a little surprised
that h over-- Yeah, no, I
guess it's right.
2/pi, yeah, right?
So I've got sin(h), I think.
And now I'm just copying this.
2/pi*sin(h), sin(h),
is that what I want?
Over one.
That's the coefficient
of sine, of cos(x).
a_1 was the
coefficient of cos(1x).
And then a_2 is the
coefficient of cos(2x).
So that will be
sin(2h). k is two,
so I have a two
down here, cos(2x).
And so on.
Yeah, I think that's
the Fourier series.
That would be the Fourier
series for the square pulse.
Yeah.
That would be the Fourier
series for the square pulse.
Could I test any
interesting cases?
Suppose h is all
the way out to pi.
Suppose I take that case.
Let h go all the way out to
pi, then what's my function?
If h=pi, then what
have I got a graph of?
Just one.
It's just a one.
If h is pi, what happens?
That becomes a one, and what
about these other things?
What is this thing when h is pi?
Zero.
All the other terms go away.
It's just a sin(2pi)
that would go away.
Yeah, so if h is pi, if I go out
to the place where I don't have
any jumps at all because it's
now all the way out there,
then these terms all disappear
and I just have this.
And I would like
to ask you and it's
going to come up on Friday too,
what happens if h goes to zero?
Well, let me just
take h going to zero.
What happens to
this whole thing?
What happens to my
function as h goes to zero?
Goes to zero, right, we've
squeezed it to nothing.
And if h is zero then
sin(h) is zero, I get 0=0,
that's not interesting
enough to mention on Friday.
But there is one case
that is important.
Suppose I make the height, yeah.
Make a guess.
Suppose I make the height higher
as I make the base smaller.
I'm going to keep
the area as one,
so if this has a base of 2h,
I'm going to have a height
of 1/(2h), So if I
keep the area at one,
so the height now is 1/(2h),
so now my square pulse,
I've divided it by 2h.
I have a 1/(2h)
multiplying everything.
And now if I let h go to zero,
something more interesting
will happen.
And what?
Just tell me first, what
would you expect to happen?
Delta.
Right, delta.
So what I'll see show up
will be the Fourier series
for the delta function.
When I divide by 2h,
so I have sin(h)'s over
h's, and of course what's the
great fact about sin(h)/h?
As h goes to zero,
it goes to, everybody
know what, that's the big deal.
Yeah.
One. sin(h) is the same size
as h for a very small h,
and approaches one.
Yeah so we'll see the
delta function Friday.
OK, so you've got a
sort of mini-lecture
instead of a real chance
to ask about homework.
Next Wednesday
should be different
because there will be
Fourier series homework,
and I'll be ready to
answer questions about it.
OK, thanks.